سحابه الدخان تضيق الخناقه على طهران ومدن
ايرانيه اخرى
فمشرات التلوث بلغت معدلات غير مسبوقه
وخطيره لم تترك للمواطن كثيرا من الخيارات
للتعامل معه
الا عند الحاجه وادعوا الحكومه للبحث عن
حل جذري
تصعب رؤيه معالم طهران مع وجود نحو 8
ملايين سياره ربوعها بات قديما وجميعها
يعمل بوقود لا يتطابق غالبا مع المعايير
الدوليه
ومع نقص الغاز الناتج عن زياده الاستهلاك
الشفوي تلجا المصانع الى العمل بماده
المازوت ما يعني انبعاث غازات سامه على
مدار اليوم ظاهره تودي سنويا بحياه نحو
20,000 مواطن يتجلى ذلك في زياده اعداد
مراجعين مشافي لمشكله في التنفس في الهواء
النقي بشكل كامل لم يدخل رئات سكان طهران
منذ سنوات
هذا التلوث خطير جدا على مرضى القلب
والتنفس الغازات السامه المنتشره في
الهواء ذات اثر سرطانيه
بعدم الخروج من منازلهم الى للضروره يبقى
لم تنجح السلطات للسنوات في حل المشكله
اكتفت بتعطيل المدارس والجامعات لايام
بدلا من اغلاق المصانع ولو بشكل مؤقت ربما
فضلت حتى الان تحمل خسائر اقتصاديه ناجمه
عن التلوث تقدر بنحو ثمانيه ملايين دولار
سنويا على تحمل عبء مكافحه الظاهره
وتكلفتها الاقل وحتى ذلك الحين يواصل
الايرانيون قتل هواء عاصمتهم
فيقتل منهم يوميا
يدعو الخبراء الى تجديد اسطول النقل العام
وابعاد المصانع عن المدينه
وتحذيراتهم تتجاوز المخاطر الصحيه
والبيئيه فهذا القاتل الصامت قد يدفع سكان
العاصمه يوما الى هجرتها عمر هواش الجزيره
طيران